l'australie est un pays immense de plus
de 7 millions et demi de kilomètres
carrés le pays compte 25 millions
d'habitants concentrés dans le sud est
du pays où se situent les grandes villes
de sydney et de melbourne l'australie
est membre du commonwealth et sa
capitale et canberra depuis 1913 le
système politique de l'offre a dit
ressemble d'ailleurs beaucoup à celui du
canada le pays à un gouverneur général
et le premier ministre scott morrison
est en poste depuis le 2018 l'australie
n'a pas de langue officielle lui la
grande majorité de la population à
l'anglais comme langue maternelle comme
le canada l'australie et est peu pris
par des autochtones au moment de
l'arrivée des premiers européens
les aborigènes représente maintenant un
peu plus de 3% de la population alors
qu'au canada il représente près d'1 5%
c'est un des pays les plus riches du
monde avec une économie qui repose sur
les services et les ressources
naturelles comme le charbon de l'or et
la lumière
l'australie est toutefois son le
continent le plus sec du monde ce qui la
rend vulnérables à la sécheresse et aux
incendies